the end of the year is upon us so we're
going to be doing a little progress
report here I hope you guys had a chance
to check out my interview from last week
with Peter Bogosian for those of you
that might have missed it my intention
with Peter was to focus on atheism as
well as critical thinking these are
ideas that Peter wrote his book about
spends most of his time talking about
and are obviously topics that I'm
interested in I think at about 13
questions prepared for Peter but like
many of my interviews the conversation
pretty much just took a life of its own
last week's case though something
particularly interesting happened no
matter how far I tried to steer the
conversation away from the regressive
left and I tried many times all roads
kept leading back to them I've mentioned
you guys a couple times now how I want
to talk about all kinds of things on
this show from science to politics to
spirituality and much more I've also
mentioned to you guys how I don't want
to solely focus on the regressive left
primarily because it doesn't necessarily
solve anything still I find myself
incredibly torn about this topic on one
hand until the last couple months we
hadn't even diagnosed the problem of the
regressive left right clearly huge
numbers of those of you on the left were
upset about how your team was being
hijacked but there wasn't a place to
come together and talk about it much
less a whole group of like-minded people
willing to share their experiences and
tell their stories for that reason I've
wanted to keep this conversation going
it's important to realize how many of us
are actually out there there are a lot
we want to fix the left but I don't
think we can without getting to critical
mass on the issue on the other hand I
don't sense that we can actually change
these regressives as I've also mentioned
before since we've started doing the
show I've seen these guys continue to
lie and smear opponents only to be
caught and then double down or even more
some people are fighting back against
these lives with facts and logic
fortunately I've had several of these
people on the show like Maajid Nawaz
Cera hater and God said others I know
only from the online space such as my
guest this week Allie rizvi Ali's an
atheist Muslim who's constantly writing
about and fighting against regressive
ideology growing up mainly in Saudi
Arabia and ultimately leaving religion
for secularism
should be a natural hero of the left
sadly he's not that's one of the many
things that we're going to talk about I
go back and forth between thinking that
fighting the regressives by putting time
and energy into discussing them is what
will ultimately do the most to change
the landscape of the left and then just
thinking that if we ignore them maybe
they'll go away I tend to think that
most of you will tell me that we have to
keep amplifying real liberal voices and
that by ignoring them we'll only let
their influence grow that's pretty much
what I think - I must say that I'm
incredibly inspired by the fact that
half the time when I see anything that
they write tweet or whatever there's an
army of people ready to combat their
[ __ ] a few people have mentioned to
me that they believe that this whole
regressive situation and the fuel that
it gives to the right is only going to
get worse before it gets better
unfortunately I think these people are
probably correct until the real
legitimate true voices of liberalism can
come back to the forefront this
conversation is always going to be stuck
between the regressives and the Trump's
it looks like we've got our work cut out
for us for 2016 my guest this week is
Ali Rizvi Ali writes for the Huffington
Post and his first book the Atheist
Muslim losing my religion but not my
identity is being published in 2016 he's
a strong advocate for the advancement of
secularism and science particularly in
the Muslim world
Ali welcome to the show Dave glad to be
on so we've been doing this as I start
almost all my shows by saying that I
guess we've been doing this on Twitter
for a while and you are another one of
these anti regressive warriors
so I'm happy that you're joining me this
week yeah you can you can't help but be
I mean it's just doing anything like
this
it's almost synonymous yeah it it
absolutely is so all right we're gonna
we're going to talk a little bit about
the regressives of course but let's
let's talk about you first I want people
to understand sort of who you are where
you come from you spent most of your
youth up until your early teens in Saudi
Arabia is that right right I did so I
pretty much grew up there I was born in
Pakistan then after that we moved to
Tripoli in Libya lived there for several
years and then I went to
Rabia where I was actually until high
school and then after that I went back
to Pakistan again for university and
then I came to Canada yeah
why were you bouncing around so much my
parents are professors and they liked
going in different places and they you
know they got really good job offers or
book very very confident and so they've
traveled all over the place yeah I mean
those just the countries we lived in and
I used to visit all over the place so
just generally when it comes to North
Africa in the Middle East and South Asia
seen a lot of places going up well
interestingly all three of those
particularly Pakistan and Libya are
probably extremely different now than
they were when you were there right
Libya I don't have too many I mean that
when we live there when out of that was
a kid so I don't I do have strong
memories of it but they're probably not
representative at all but the way it is
right now now and Pakistan is also very
different than it used to be and I
haven't been there for a while now I
can't go right so we'll talk about why
you can't go there in a little bit but
let's talk about Saudi Arabia for a bit
because it's such an important player in
world politics and its relationship to
the United States and I feel like people
actually know very little about Saudi
Arabia the nature of our relationship
what was it like growing up there your
parents as professors obviously came
from the I'm assuming that was
middle-class sort of educated middle
class well how did that relate to
religion and secular realism and all
that it was um it was it was complicated
so like another way I describe it is
that my own nuclear family like my
parents and my siblings are sort of a
liberal progressive type of Shia Muslim
family and so we had that and then
outside that I was in the private
American school the American
International School in Riyadh the time
so the school was you know obviously was
American so we had American textbooks we
listened to American music and you know
it wasn't it was an American school that
had people from about 80 different
nationalities so it was a truly
international school and then
outside of that stepped out of that it
was you know cover your hair women can't
drive you know five times prayer and if
you're outside during the prayer you
know you'll get caught by one of the
Matawa as they call him which is the
religious police so it was strange so
you know all of these three things but
when you know when you're growing up
with something is a kid that is normal
for you that's what you think
everything's like so I actually think
that was a good thing to be exposed to
all of those worlds at the same time so
I was you know when for instance when
9/11 happened I could you know the
Saudis coming up in there and I remember
the mentality that there was there one
one thing I described in my book is when
I was in fifth grade at the American
school we'd made paper snowflakes out of
you know if we hold up a piece of paper
you cut snowflakes turn um and you know
we decorated them with glue and glitter
and our names and we were happy I was
about ten years old and it was even
though was an American school the Saudi
Ministry of Education used to send an
inspector once in a while to make sure
everything's okay everything's going
according to the rules and he came in
and he actually cut one of the tips off
of each of snowflakes he was very angry
cut them off and we asked our teacher
what was going on so I can what is this
and then she told us about starved David
and why we can't anything that has six
points that sort of symbolizes that and
that was our this is a whole class of
ten year olds that was our introduction
at least my introduction to the Jews Wow
right so um and this was just a spot
check from an inspector but they're kids
in Saudi Arabia will go with Saudi
schools they have the stuff in their
textbooks the guy who did that spot
check for us was actually he actually
writes the curriculum for the rest of
them
so when 9/11 happened I saw that kind of
culture those people coming in from
there and then the people in my school
like the Americans they're the ones
being attacked over here was it was
really strange seeing it because I kind
of grown up with both sides in parallel
you know the all my teachers were
American a lot of my friends were from
the US and Canada on the other hand the
country I was living in was a place
while the hijackers came through so at
fifth grade so you're prolly I guess
that's about eleven years old or so was
that sort of where your secular
awakening was was happening is that the
time of that or how religious actually
was was your family where you were you
guys away from it already or break that
down for me
well my family was my family was sort of
liberal religious I mean there were
Muslim they were believing Muslims we
used to go through the you know we did
the Ramadan thing we stood where she is
so we should do the Muharram morning my
parents used to pray you know on and off
but usually they made it to like two or
three times a day you know on average so
you know they were there must be an
interesting diagram of people praying
and then the sort of drop off as it gets
later in the day right I I don't know a
lot of Muslims who actually believe pray
five times a day every time I watch TV
and it's you know this is a slight
tangent but every time you know you
Google North American Muslim or American
Muslim you'll get a whole picture of
people with head scarves and you know
people in mosques and so on but they're
just as much representative of us
Muslims as as you know any militant
group right that's not what Karen isne
or not why which is exactly why we
should all be talking to people like you
more because I have no faith that the
media is giving us examples of any
forget religion ethnicity whatever it is
the media gives us such bad examples of
everybody that that's why we have to
talk to the outliers right yeah you
understand it in a way and I'm sorry
we're going away from your original
questions that's fine that's fine
um yet I understand it in a way because
you know for instance if there's
something some story you're relating to
Christianity you're not exactly usually
gonna call in a pastor or you know
somebody who's was a priest or something
like that who's an expert with G&E but
um the thing with Muslims is it's
different when you think Jerry Seinfeld
with David Letterman you don't think Jew
right but way right well I don't think
Letterman's Jewish but either way
I thought he was median so it's it's
close enough comedian is a whole
different that's a separate I think
right that's that's another thing right
but you know when you when to when it
cups of Muslims I mean Dave Chapelle dr.
oz Jack O'Neill like all of these guys I
mean these are people who are Muslims
but that's not who you said that that's
not the representation even though
they're right here in front of our faces
so when you see it on TV it's always the
one with the headscarf
every almost every non wasn't my know
work so the Muslim of work has gone for
beer with him afterwards you know a lot
of people have dated Muslim girls and
they've very few of them actually wear
the headscarf but I'm pretty sure if
Shaq was the main representative for
Muslims things would be extremely
different right now yep wouldn't they
yeah probably probably for the better
um so wait so tell me a little more so
your family so you guys were sort of
religious but not that religious you
were getting some of this at the school
but that was obviously Americanized
right keep going so I mean my my main
the first time I was truly skeptical of
that religion and God was when I was
five years old and I actually had a
cousin and she was three and this is
that she lived in London and she had
childhood leukemia so you know she was
close to my age I was five she was three
you know we play mates and when she was
dying everybody who came into the room
so this was like an hour in the culture
you know last moments everyone walks in
though some kids were there he was there
and it's a you know a child's death is
special food cancer it's absolutely
horrific you know so cancer doesn't
discriminate same amount of pain and
adult feels is what a three year old
childhood cool so and at that time there
wasn't really any good cure for
childhood acute lymphoblastic leukemia
either so at that point my mother and my
aunt were praying and crying and I was
standing there with my father and I
asked my father like you know what's
going on I was watching her in pain and
he said that God's taking her back God's
taking her to a better place and keeping
her with him so I'm thinking okay that's
that's not such a bad thing so why are
they crying and why they praying so hard
and they're like they're they're begging
God
to take her away they want him to you
know like stop the pain or not take away
and to me that could my mind used to
play tug of war at school so I was
thinking of the tug of war game where
there's this God is all-powerful and
apparently and we're on the other end
and we're playing and it just seemed
like a very sadistic thing to do
yeah it also it also sounds like such a
losing proposition if you're the
believer so if in this case you're your
father assuming he was a believer or
that maybe he was just playing the role
as a father but it's a losing
proposition if you pretty much know
medically that the child is not going to
make it and yet you have these people
praying and you know the outcome is
pretty much in front what are you
actually saying about prayer is also an
interesting angle I mean that's the
other thing and I think if God is like
all-powerful and there's a three year
old kid in pain you don't and find I
understand you know you have to take the
kid back they don't like don't draw it
out don't draw out the agony because
cancer deaths are terrible so we you
know at that point the clarity of
five-year-old mind I obviously that I
remember this very clearly it's one of
my earliest strongest memories just
because the intensity of it and after
that I thought I was like okay nobody's
really gonna be happy with this god
character anymore but the next week
every ritual everything God was a hero
you know everyone whose continued
pranked him so it didn't make a lot of
sense to me and then after that I
thought I was like maybe well all these
guys you know all the adults grown-ups
think it makes sense so maybe I'm the
one who's crazy but then I'd see I'd
watch TV and there'd be a disaster
natural disaster tornado or a flood or
something and the lone survivor or two
would say you know I'm god bless you
know God saved me I'm so thankful to God
knows I'd always think you know what did
the other people do so as a kid it was
always there and then I dabbled in and
out of being religious to some extent
like whenever had exams finals that
that's where the prayer would kick in
yeah so it was like my cousin used to
call the bribing god they're like
reviving God he was a very religious guy
yeah the bad God probably took your
bribes I'm guessing you were a pretty
good student the end it turn
doubt that I was fairly yeah I did well
in school like I did turned out whether
I prayed or not God somehow was okay
with me but all those kids with HIV in
Africa somehow yeah just somehow my
grades were okay but HIV for the kids in
Africa not so much yeah alright so you
you have this awakening and it's
happening where where was the full sort
of more adult version of your awakening
were you still in Saudi Arabia or was
that when you had left already I had I'd
left I'd gone I'd gone to medical school
at that point in Pakistan I'd finish I'd
completed it and towards the end of it I
had actually really started reading um
the the well I'd started reading the
scripture and everything the Quran when
I was much younger I think when the
internet came around and I wanted to do
more research I was able to find more
things so if this was around ninety nine
or so it was already in my 20s I'm a
little up there so so I started you know
when I actually started reading it then
and when people got more and more
defensive about it the more I talked
especially in Pakistan when you talk to
people they give you all of these
responses like you know those aren't
true Muslims or you know this isn't sort
of peace or you know that thing that
you're recording from the Quran that's
us miss translated or misinterpreted or
it's a metaphor you know and whatever
the excuse was and eventually I started
seeing through it and then I I think it
was actually one day when it hit me I'm
like this
I shouldn't even be considering this I
mean this is a guy lived inside a fish
you know there's a yeah it says it says
in it I'd hear that you know the in the
Quran for me was a Quran for a lot of
people it's a Bible innovation by the
way we should note that they're all
equally crazy there's plenty of evil
stuff in all of them we want you know we
want to be good liberals here so let's
not pile on one right there is plenty of
awful stuff in the Old Testament well
every store they always say that if
Moses hadn't hallucinate adapt the Old
Testament and you know Muhammad could
have plagiarized it
yes it is and there's a lot of
similarities no pork
there's no foreskin for miles there's
Shalom and Salam and then both of their
nicknames are bow it's in a way there's
a you know there are a lot of
similarities between especially between
Judaism and Islam and and the violence
in the books is absolutely and that's
that's an obvious thing but I used to
think I'm like what are you doing when
people would quote verse 434 which says
that you can beat your wife if you fear
disobedience as a last resort and they
justify it now like well no it actually
means this or it's only as a last resort
nice to think I'm like if I had written
this in my book and the book came out
last week you guys would be killing me
for this I mean there's the word you
wouldn't be looking for contacts you
wouldn't be looking at alternative
interpretations that's a luxury that we
only afford two holy books I mean we
don't read Alice in Wonderland that way
resurrected you know the and did you
know people like for example Reza Aslan
so on be like that is it this is we
should not read this literally like in
the worst thing is the people who read
it literally I was actually on a show I
was on the agenda with Steve Paikin here
in Toronto and I was sitting next to
Shabbir Ali who's a an Islamic scholar
and at one point he actually said he's
like look people misquote the Quran by
quoting it literally and I was just
thinking that's that was one of the most
amazing sentences that's a great quote
right there
yeah he's a great guy but he said and I
used to think I'm like I understand why
they're so terrified of people quoting
it literally any script ever because
it's terrifying if you quote if you
quote those words exactly the way that
they're written or exactly the way they
were said by God apparently then it's a
terrifying thing you know so they say
well you have to look at the
interpreters and the scholars and then
you listen to scholars and they're
saying these human beings their
explanations of what's God what God's
Word is actually means more than what
God's Word is itself which again doesn't
make any sense and Isis and al-qaeda and
the Taliban these are these people
they're not quoting scholars I mean
they're they're quoting scripture
recording
the deep yeah you know after the Paris
attacks I got into it on Twitter with
one of my one of my friends on the Left
who immediately was you know with within
while the thing I think while the event
was still happening so literally they
hadn't caught anybody yet I mean there
were bodies still on the floor at the
theater he immediately went to the
American foreign policy stuff and then a
few minutes after that they released the
guys who did it Isis actually released
the statement and there was a ton of
Scripture in there and I said well what
do you think about this and then the
conversation sort of dwindled off into
nothing and I and I think that's part of
what this whole schism here on the left
that we've been talking so much about is
related to you know like it's Scripture
it's written word that somebody is
believing and taking into action and
then also there's a lot of messed up
foreign policy stuff by every country in
the world yeah I always find it I find
it interesting that whenever I'm
debating or I'm having a discussion that
anybody usually if it's someone who's
moderate or someone or an academic or
someone else in Islamic studies for
instance um they don't want to talk
about the scripture like well come on
let's not talk about the scripture as if
it's sort of beneath them like you know
we're going to talk about the social
logical implications of this you know
how does religion work out as I did
identity formation and all of these
other things economics and so on but
whenever I talk to a guy with a beard
you know someone who's more
fundamentalist and I like at times else
and I said this on the show too should
be rally to I was like oh let's not get
into the whole scripture thing but they
almost always turn outside no that's
what's important that's what the
religion is so the people who are
actually believing it and going along
with the tenets of it and actually
following the example of the Prophet and
so on these are people who actually take
scripture very very seriously the rest
of people don't and I think it's because
there is an element of rationality and
they just can't believe did like okay
this is a book but nobody really
believes is yeah so last week my guess
was Peter Bogosian who you're probably
familiar with and he wrote a book called
a manual for creating atheists and one
of the things that I thought was most
interesting about it was that he
basically said you know because these
beliefs are not Bey
based in critical thinking or
rationality and that people have to take
this leap of faith that actually if you
can really sit someone down and you do
it sort of with the right intent and and
a clear mind you can start pulling the
the underpinnings away in an effective
way and you can actually convert people
in into free thinkers I'm gonna guess
that you've done quite a bit about
yourself
the only reason I do what I do
Dave is because of that any time
somebody tells me it's like another way
that you talk to people it's not gonna
work people aren't gonna change their
mind um that is absolutely not true and
I've got um you know if you look at my
inbox like my email inbox
almost on a daily basis you know I get
messages I mean the most recent one was
got if you read that post at one fire
hose by a friend of mine see me Ramon
she wrote about the dead telling
difference between a moderate and
radical she lives in California she's a
pediatrician I'll send it to you yeah
please do it yeah and she um so it went
viral got thousands and thousands of
shares and so on and she got a message
of just a few days ago and there was
this woman who actually wore than the
cop was very conservative family and
she'd read it and um she has now she's
seriously thinking about taking it off
like well it's completely shaken the way
that she's think about things the way
that she grew up and these are stories
that I hear every day and I hear them
more than ever in muslim-majority
countries and and this is what's so
interesting is that in North America
generally the the Muslims because
they're they're used to the free speech
and the open discourse and everything
they are they like to have a respectful
approach so like okay criticize religion
at least be respectful of us they don't
like the tone that somebody like for
example like Richard Dawkins or Bill
Maher takes right however in the Muslim
in these Muslim majority countries where
they're living under these sort of
theocratic dictatorship so even though
they're not officially theocratic
dictatorships almost all of them are um
for them they that really resonates for
them with them the with a more
aggressive tone because they're a press
why they can't speak
so they're angry they're frustrated the
last person that they heard who spoke
went out me got hacked to death and in
Dhaka and yeah up so you know they they
are they're angry they're frustrated and
they they want that kind of tone they
they feel like the respectful discourse
is the luxury of the privileged people
who are able to wear values like freedom
of speech and you can take that who take
that for granted that that I mean that's
really fascinating because you know I've
talked a lot about how people you know
especially its Dawkins mr are the two
that have sort of become you know the
most outspoken on atheism really and and
talking about the doctrine of Islam I
think they're pretty pretty clear it's
out there in the Muslim majority country
so yeah but I what I think what I think
is interesting here is that I hear from
atheists will say well Dawkins Ammar
they're there to offense you know it's
too offensive there'd be you know
they're putting out too much and they're
not speaking in a you know a friendly
way so atheists are angry at them for
being atheists but interestingly you're
saying that in foreign places in foreign
countries they need to hear it in that
light and that's incredible because they
actually want to say it that way I mean
if you the most sort of aggressive
sounding atheists that you'll meet from
the Muslim world are the ones who
actually grew up there yeah the ones
with the accents are the ones who made
it here after living there who think
that all you know Americans kind of take
freedom of speech and polite discourse
and so on for granted so they are angry
they want a more angry sort of
expression of it but there I mean there
is a point I do understand why people
different things work on different
people I was give the example of the
civil rights movement how you know Rosa
Parks acted in silence you know she was
sitting on that on the bus and she said
I'm not gonna move back on the other
hand Martin Luther King was the diplomat
you know so he was he was sort of more
political he was conciliatory used to
try to make reasoned arguments and talk
to the other side on the other hand you
had Malcolm X who was more militant and
all of those approaches had had a role
that are very key role and they work on
different people
my approach is probably more sort of I
tried to be reasonable I have reasonable
arguments I try to do that at least but
I do appreciate people who do the kind
of thing that Bill Maher and Richard
Dawkins do because I know that it
resonates I know that it's a um it's
very satisfying to a lot of people
growing up there and I remember when I
was growing up there whenever I would
hear people say things like that was
George Carlin at the time but you know I
remember you know seeing little things
that George Carlin that had done and the
way that he talked about religion it was
just so in-your-face and so like naked
Lee open some of it that it was
extremely satisfying to watch because
that's something that you could not see
and you'd show it to your friends was on
a VHS tape and show to your friends in
the clip where you said it and yeah you
see the shock on their faces and it was
this is something really satisfying
about yeah well I tell my friend Kelly
Carlin who's been on the show who's
George's daughter and I tell Kelly
literally once a week I'll call her or
text her and say God God ironically I'll
say gosh you know I really wish that
your dad was around now because we're so
trapped and I think this will get us to
the next portion of this conversation
but we're so trapped in this PC world
right now and we're so afraid of
language and we're so afraid of
offending everybody and already as
you've said sometimes you have to offend
people to actually break through it's
not your style clearly right like you're
not looking to end everybody but I end
up doing it anyway I think that the
needs of the price but you know that the
thing is like I hear this a lot I hear a
lot of people say this especially a lot
of my Muslim friends in here living in
the US and in Canada is that the free
freedom of speech does not mean the
freedom of to offend and I would say to
them I'm like there's no such thing as
freedom of speech without freedom and
offense yeah every there is absolutely
no major revolutionary change that has
ever happened in history that did not
piss off a lot of people so let's talk a
little bit about
friends on the left because I think
they've they failed us but particularly
you and and your friends and family
probably in in this regard they have
somehow aligned themselves with forces
that don't want you to speak up against
doctrine and and that's really
incredible it's the reverse of
liberalism and I'll let you take it from
there well I mean I that's what I think
I think if you're against bad ideas
should be against bad ideas anywhere if
you oppose homophobia and you think
homophobia is a terrible thing it should
be a bad thing
and unit you pointed out every time it's
in someone cost a Bible or every time
it's in a Donald Trump speech um you
know or a Ted Cruz speech or whatever it
is then it that same idea is also a bad
idea when it's in the Quran and if it's
being said by Muslims including a lot of
liberal Muslims I mean that is something
that even a lot of liberal Muslims in
North America haven't warmed up to yet
so these I understand like there's the I
think there's a instinct to try and
protect the minority but the ideology
that the minority here subscribes to
just coincidentally and I'm not saying
that they follow it the same way that
they do in other more violent parts of
the world but that same ideology the
same book is being used to kill people
right and to throw gay people off
rooftops in other parts of the world so
I think it's it is very confusing for
everybody because you know the way that
it happens is you know people see here
especially non-muslims they see on TV
they see a group called the Islamic
state quoting the Quran accurately and
actually saying quoting verses that say
fight the disbelievers and charge them
you know the non-muslim talks and you
know God will destroy them and so on so
they're quoting these verses they're
saying Allah Akbar right so they're
they're obviously professing their faith
and then they're chopping someone's
heads off or throwing somebody off a
rooftop and the reaction over here often
when they see that is that they
immediately jump to defending the faith
that this is the real faith and a moment
they say that you know you bring the
scripture to them you're like well what
about this verse they
quarter just like you did with your
friend you know what about this verse
that they quoted it said this says
exactly the words that they said here
match the action and then they start
defending the verses and the book you
know misinterpretation out of context
and so on all the you know that's sort
of the excuses that you're here and so
now what you have is you have moderate
Muslims here defending the same book
that the fundamentalists over there are
quoting and citing to kill non-muslims
over there that the non-muslims are
looking at this side of the world and
that is toxic because it actually makes
that gives the impression the modern
Muslims over here are pretty much that
they subscribe to the same ideology
they're just not acting on it which is
not true well that impression it gives
not only is it not true but it seems to
me that people like you people like
Majnu oz Cera hater great people in my
estimation who I think are fighting for
the right things who are applying the
same principles across the board they're
not looking at your faith or your race
or your nationality they're saying here
are humanistic principles right that I
want to apply to everyone the left is
the one attacking them did you ever
expect that that was going to be the
push back for you
mm-hmm it's for me I know I didn't it's
it honestly I mean I knew that there
were a lot of sort of moderate Muslims
that would have problems with it I just
didn't think that the sort of these CJ
Romans and the you know I guess you know
whatever we call the regressive left
um they I can't keep track of all them
yeah yes so this is just the one for
most recent memory you don't keep a list
on the side of your bed I have a
chalkboard I'm just always adding to the
list you don't have that I I can't I
have I have better things to do I don't
have enough time or crayons to display
that's left I am spending a fortune in
chalk it's ridiculous no but the the
thing with regressive left and on a
serious note is they're they're reacting
to you know the pushback that we're
getting is we
action and for them I just look at that
entire thing is a very very reactionary
thing their only argument only argument
they have to anything is bigoted
islamaphobe house Muslim or you know the
brown skinned white I don't know but
what it was yeah it's a lot of that yeah
nope there's that that's the only
argument that they have and I I'm
actually encouraged I'm optimistic about
it I mean if you looked at in the past
every time one of these attacks happened
and there was some conversation to be
taking place on TV about us on CNN or
MSNBC or fox or anything it would always
be wet Reza Aslan could come on or
they'd call you know got the comedian
guy on CNN Dean Obeidallah so him and so
they would you know they that that's
what they would do but now I'm not
seeing that you know since these new
attacks and now that everything is
getting even more serious you know I'm
seeing more of Majin on TV I'm seeing
more of Australia money on TV you know
I'm seeing voices like this I'm seeing
ayaan Hirsi Ali being called on to talk
about things so I I think that most of
the even the so-called mainstream media
is seeing through it Bill Maher actually
said on la shala he was on or the one
with Austin Imani when he interviewed
her he actually said that he's more and
more liberals are coming up to him and
agreeing with him they used to get a lot
of crap from them before but he doesn't
anymore
um and I think that that's changing and
I think that this hold that what we call
the regressive left is simply responding
to them well I got to tell you I mean
that sounds incredibly uplifting because
you know I'm so in this and having these
conversations and as I said at the top
of the show I find a lot of it
exhausting and I battled sort of between
back and forth of like can I move on
from this topic and every time I move on
I feel like I get sucked back in and you
know I'll put it away and then I'll
suddenly see your your Twitter fight
with someone or I'll see you know
Greenwald attacking Sam or whatever it
is but I think you gave me a little
something to go with there
because the idea that they are acting
out more it's getting more like a child
having a tantrum and maybe it's just
because they realize this is the last
vestige of an ideology that's just not
going to work because we've woke up
right yeah I think that they're they're
prodding basically for a response um and
do we give it to them you know in all
honestly a lot of times I mean I'll
ignore it for a while and I and I you
know like with I'll ignore it for a very
long time but if I do decide to respond
inside response strong and usually the
response is not for the person making it
it's for the rest of the audience for
everybody else who's watching the
conversation I mean I I'm under no
illusions that I can I can change the
minds of you know a lot of these sort of
hacks on that that are a lot of the
trolls that actually try to you know
dissuade us and try to deflect
everything but I think that for the
wider audience who's seen the
conversations it's good for them to see
what they're what they're dealing to see
both sides of it and to see that play
out you know on whether on social media
or in books or in articles and so on so
I think that you know the you know I'll
give you I'd I think that they're
reacting to for instance with Sam Harris
you know Sam Harris has a lot of great
ideas he started a lot of really good
conversation in fact everything that
we're seeing right now with the rise of
Donald Trump and so the hijacking of
this conversation by the sort of because
the xenophobic paranoid side mm-hmm and
now them gaining ground and capitalizing
on on the on the fear and the concern
and the confusion that I think he's
feeling something that the left should
have done but they didn't do right and
they should have done it from a sort of
a moral honest position and now it's
being done by the right from a
xenophobic bigoted position this is
something that Sam predicted a long time
ago that you wrote about it and now I I
think you know what's happening is that
you know there's all of these spats back
and forth with the green walls and the
romans and you know all these other sort
of characters and they're deflecting
from
what was initially that the actual thing
that was causing this response in the
first place right right so what go ahead
sorry no no I was just saying we should
continue with exactly what we were doing
before is what we should be doing we
should just be talking about the ideas
um sticking to the big picture I mean I
came from when I when I came here um to
Canada into the u.s. after living for
you know twenty four years and in most
of majority countries I wanted to bring
I want to talk about big ideas you know
I wasn't really concerned about
microaggressions or you know regressive
laughter you know all of these other
issues I actually wanted to talk about
the big ideas and and I've noticed that
the more a lot of us over here are you
know there are people who try to pull us
into these more sort of petty Jerry
Springer like conversations and I think
it would serve us best to just ignore it
yeah well I listen I'm doing my best to
do that and I I know I'm saying that
especially after what happened last week
so um we with me as well once in a while
you know or what but once in a while I
think you have to do it and you have to
hat look had all of this terrible stuff
and all of the slandering and all the
stuff not happened then I think the
awakening you know let's say you were
awake probably before I was I mean my
real awakening to this literally was
that that night watching Real Time with
that athletic so had it not happened I
may have been slumbering through you
know the left going further and further
to the left so in a weird way it is
actually very empowering but I that's
actually a perfect segue to want to talk
about next which you're touching upon
which is that by not dealing with this
in an honest fashion by not really
allowing the people to speak about it
the Liberals to speak about it in a fair
way you're handing this to Trump and
we're seeing this we're seeing this
right now in America we're seeing this
in Europe where for the first time ever
in places like Sweden and Denmark
far-right parties are running on anti
immigration because it's all wrapped up
in well we're afraid to be called racist
so it's crazy right yeah they're they're
all everybody's Islamophobia phobic
right yeah the fear of being called a
sound phobic and um yeah I think I think
you're you're absolutely right and we
did in a way hand this to trump um the
problem over here is that there's Trump
is not actually responsible for all of
this anti-muslim hate and all this
anti-muslim sentiment that's happening
so let's be clear on that the the party
that's responsible for that is the
attackers the Isis that people would
talk to parents of people who are making
all these videos of beheadings of you
know journalists and so on I mean these
are the people that the Americans and
Westerners in general are reacting to
right but wait let me stop you there
because what would you say to my friends
on the Left who would say well it's
America that created Isis well and
America did there it's obviously a
complicated thing you know u.s. foreign
policy there's u.s. foreign policy
there's nationalism there's greed
there's power there's you know corporate
oxi and all these other characters that
people talk about racism and misogyny
and you know tell me like you know why
do you always pick on religion when you
have all of these factors like I always
turn around I tell them I'm like I agree
with you
mijin belongs right up there in the same
category with racism and greed and
misogyny and you know terrible things
that everybody else is doing so I do
think that US foreign policy is a factor
and the argument has never been that
religion is the only cause of religious
sentiments the only cause that we're not
asking people to recognize or to think
that it's not everything else it's
religion we're saying the only thing
that we're going against is the idea
that it's everything but religion to
ignore the religious aspect of it or the
fact that beliefs actually have
consequences
yeah and that's because we want to
respect it so you're saying earlier is
that what Donald Trump is doing is that
there is a lot of confusion there's a
lot of fear that a lot of people have
right now legitimately I the way that
you channel that the way that leaders
channel that is what makes all the
difference you know so Donald Trump has
basically fed up
that he's drummed it up more for his own
opportunist
opportunistic purposes and he's turned
into let's ban all Muslims if there was
another reasonable voice you know on on
the left and they had channeled that and
they had kind of responsibly dealt with
it in an honest way then we may see a
different outcome you know when when
people confuse us when leadership
matters and that's where the Liberals I
think failed so that that's interesting
that naturally I agree with that premise
but I think you could really take it to
the candidates themselves so for example
Bernie Sanders who I like a lot
obviously and Hillary when you take the
candidates that are on the left that are
the Democrats when they won't say
Islamic extremism or they won't say
violent jihad or whatever whatever the
term you want to you know everyone get
so caught up in terms that I hate even
using words at this point but when they
won't even say the terms and they'll
just say religious extremism or
something I think that that they also
then hand it to trump because Trump's
just given you he's just giving you the
the wide you know the wide net to go
with and they're and they're still
playing the games of political
correctness no but that's exactly and
that that is kind of what I was trying
to say is that they do it so there there
are two things that have to be done
right now one is that the rights of
Muslims have to be protected and number
two Islamic doctrine has to be
challenged and criticized both of those
things have to be done what the what the
Hillary Clinton the Bernie Sanders side
is doing is they're trying to protect
all the rights of Muslims without
actually challenging the ideology and
what the Donald Trump the right these
people are doing is that they're
challenging the ideology without
protecting the rights of the people yeah
so yeah and and it's not an under people
think that that's contradictory it's not
contradictory at all this is what it was
Voltaire who said right like I will I
may despise what you say but I'll defend
to the death your right to say that's
the same principle um and it's not that
difficult to do if we have a responsible
leader who actually does that I think
that that is something that a lot of
people would relate to and they would
understand that okay we will challenge
doctrine a lot of Muslims though
her like you know you're challenging my
religion this is my identity
people incorporate their beliefs into
their identity and the dialogue would be
well yes you're a person respect your
right to believe what you believe but
you know these are ideas ideas are
different we're talking about the ideas
we're not talking about you as a person
right so that if there was a political
party that was running you know that
said we're gonna throw gays off roofs
and we're gonna stone women and kill
apostates you probably be against that
political party but as a religion as a
religious doctrine it gets a little
extra credit or something that's that's
the thing like there's a lot of
completely it would be like completely
strange things that we do for example
neonatal circumcision like infant
circumcision is one of those things
where you know we I mean my parents did
it you know my siblings have done it
like to their nephews and so on it's a
very it's legal you know everybody does
it but when you really think about it if
there was a gay if there was no religion
behind it or as I like to say if Abraham
didn't wasn't so fond of [ __ ] yeah
you would did this would be child abuse
you'd have pediatricians getting sued
for this all right so I so I want to
circle back a little bit to the
beginning of the conversation and and
your history and your story for a second
because you identify as an atheist
Muslim is that correct well atheist
Muslim was the title of my book
doctrinally I can't be an atheist Muslim
but the whole point of the book is to
talk about the incorporation of religion
into identity so there are a lot of I
mean wait so I'll explain it this way
when I first came here um two years
after I permanently moved to permanently
moved to Canada is when the 9/11 attacks
happened and when that happened I you
know I had this whole conversation in my
head you know as part of a Muslim family
I grew up with Muslim people I I was in
all the Muslim traditions the that
Ramadan you know a lot of things are
cultural they're reasonably cultural but
there's some sort of Muslim things like
a seizure like Ramadan so into so that
was all a part of me but at the same
time I wasn't a huge fan of the ideology
um
so when I when I came here the 9/11
attacks happened this whole conversation
had been going on my head for a very
long time suddenly exploded was all you
know on TV was on the radios everywhere
and there were two sides there was sort
of the liberal side and they said that
you know Muslims must be protected as a
minority so any criticism of Islam is
bigotry and on the right it was that and
this is the sort of the Fox News
narrative was that you know Islam is
sort of an it's a it's a it's a violent
religion so Muslims you know we need to
profile everybody you know we need to
clamp down on immigration you know all
of those things and there was one
mistake both of them were doing is they
were conflating the ideology with the
people they're ruining the ideology with
the identity and this and this is where
I wish for actually a middle ground and
I I think what we're seeing we're seeing
the same thing with the regressive left
on one side and you know the the Donald
Trump phenomenon on the other is the
same thing as a conflation of this sort
of ideology and people and by people I
mean people who are a Muslim Muslim just
because it's as if birth identity
because most people are Muslim because
it's just a birth identity right so so
for you personally while you're
obviously an atheist so you're a
non-believer do you are you culturally
Muslim like what does that actually mean
to you at this point like I assume your
family probably does some holiday stuff
maybe you don't believe in it but do you
culturally identify that way me for
example I'm an atheist I am NOT a
believer but there are Jewish traditions
that my family that my grandparents did
that their grandparents did that their
grandparents did that my family does so
I can do that and it doesn't have a
religious connotation it has a cultural
connotation to me that's it that's
exactly what it is I mean I enjoy and I
enjoy the feast of Ramadan Ramadan is a
great time I mean you do you have people
frosting I don't necessarily fast but
I'm therefore that's a bit much the very
good yeah yeah um and I like to eat
celebrations I like and I have little
nieces and nephews and they all dress up
and you know I get them gifts and so I
enjoy that as much as anybody I'm on you
know I very close to my fan
my nuclear family and my extended family
and a lot of them are believing Muslims
so I do take part in that but there's
also another place where it affects you
for instance I read a story about this
kid who was called was beat up at school
and because and they said that you know
she was an isis baby or isis kid and i
got out of my knees and I don't want my
knees to go through that I did like this
whole thing that's happening in the u.s.
right now you know I don't want my and
I've got I've got nieces and nephews in
the u.s. too and you know so I don't
want them to go through that it would be
completely heartbreak I'd be devastated
if I heard that my own niece went
through something like that just because
now she has a Muslim name you know a
Muslim sounding name she looks a certain
way so it affects you at that level too
so when things like that happen or you
know I recently I recently posted about
this I have a friend who's a physician
uh he's and he actually he's in
California and he went to a party
recently and there's a woman who came up
to him and said you know you she called
him a Taliban terrorists and so on and
she was a little drunk and fortunately
the people he was around jumped in and
you know they defended him and they
called her out on it
but these are things that are how then
he's also nephews by the way so he's
from a Muslim background and you know so
when things like this happened this is
something that could happen to me as
well
it could happen to my own family so on
that level
I do identify with the sort of you know
what a lot of Muslims are going through
on the other hand I also get
prejudice I mean I guess apostates get
it from not only the people who target
Muslims but the Muslims who target ah
States so it's a bit of a double whammy
there but you did you so you do relate
to it and this it's a very complicated
thing when you have that mixture of
ideology and identity yeah is it it's a
very complicated thing to navigate and
it's not as binary and as simple as you
know what you hear I do when you hear
someone like Glenn Greenwald talk about
some like Donald Trump talk or do I
think are served very similar yeah yeah
well that's why I phrased the question
the way I did because I don't see an
inherent contradiction there I think
that everything that you've described
sounds completely feasible to me and if
anything it's not just feasible
it sounds preferable to me because
you're taking the logical and the and
the secular side of your of your
existence and fully acknowledging that
and then also acknowledging your history
and your family and all that so that to
me that to me makes full sense and more
people should be trying to do that yeah
I think there's a Philip Zukerman is
this he's this writer who wrote a book
called I think it's called living the
secular life um I'm pretty sure that's
what it's called
and that he actually talks about
secularizing religion himself and I he
also did an interview with sam harris
sam harris interviewed him for his a
blog and he talks about that as a very
sort of seminal step in moving towards
secularism is that you know you take the
holidays and take the rituals you take
the the community aspect of it now they
have sunday assemblies and everything so
that those are examples of things that
people can do and out you know religions
actually move toward secularism you
talked about Reform Judaism which was
which is interesting is you know Judaism
and Islam again very similar you know
how God revealed the Quran directly to
Muhammad in the same way God supposedly
revealed the Torah to to Moses at the
tabernacle in Mount Sinai and so on and
it was considered the literal word of
God it was actually considered the
blueprint for creation Genesis at one
point so it was meant to even predate
creation and that's how it was thought
of at a time and then in the you know
late late eighteenth I think it was the
it was the nineteenth century early 19th
century when the reformed Judaism
movement really took hold in it it got
demoted from literal word of God to
divinely inspired yeah so suddenly
something was you know written by the
hands of human beings and revelation
became a progressive thing you know
sometimes it was a quality they adopted
a lot of
their values and so on and gonna change
so when people say well the quran is
infallible you know how you gonna change
it and I always think they're good the
Quran there's precedent for that there's
actually precedent for that with Judaism
with because the Catholicism for
instance I mean there's a lot of
Catholics who are pro-choice a lot of
practice birth control many of them they
fornicate to their heart's content but
you know you still go and they observe
Lent and they celebrate Christmas and
Easter nobody kicks them out of the
church saying you know you're not a
Catholic yeah what yeah well for the
record I told this to Peter last week
but I actually went to Mount Sinai in
1997 I went to Egypt I went to Sinai I
hiked the mountain and literally nothing
happened I asked I mean I really did I
was at that place in life you know 20 or
21 or so or 19 and I I went there trying
to have something and talk to somebody
and and nobody nobody talked back bad
experience the first time you don't want
to repeat it again you don't all right
so I want to end with this because you
have brought up a phrase that I think
you've hashtagged and I want to make
sure that when this thing takes off that
you're fully credited for it and
hopefully I'll have a little something
to do with it but you've talked about
the new center and I think it's it's the
right phrase for what we've been looking
for I think it fits it fits because we
have this left-right paradigm but it
also fits the center of this liberal
split between you know the regressives
and the say classic liberals so can you
just tell me a little bit more about
what you think the new center is and
what we can all do to get people there I
say well it's basically what I described
here that you know what you have that
when it comes to purely this aspect of
Islamism and jihadism and sort of
religious extremism if you say even
though that's a misnomer it's it's about
a separating ideology from identity it's
about being able to stand up for the
rights of people but at the same time
challenge ideas when you attack and
challenge ideas that's how societies
move forward if you attack and debase
people that's what splits people up
that's what actually rips us apart so
being able to do to make that
distinction is very important I don't
think either side is doing it you know I
think that the center is more
national and honored on a broader level
too I've always found it bizarre that
you know if you're fiscally conservative
and then you know you suddenly you have
to be pro-life right thank you why does
all of that go together
I think it's absolutely ridiculous
people should be able to yeah you know
how different you know I should be able
to think that okay I believe these
fiscally conservative principles sure
it's time I'm socially liberal or I
could have libertarian president there's
no rational I don't think you can be a
rationally thinking person and be
aligned with one side or the other yeah
well that's a whole other topic figuring
out how the the politicians figured out
to make everything a wedge issue so
somehow gay rights if you were for gay
rights
you were also for you know low taxes
like it just doesn't make any sense do
you think there's any chance for a
political movement with that because
when you I saw it you did hashtag
NewsCenter and I thought maybe there's
politics there not just not just this
sort of internal discussion that we'll
all have and hopefully get it out there
more but actually this could maybe be a
political movement
I would I would like that that's why I
brought up the whole fiscally
conservative socially liberal thing is
because yeah you know when when I grew
up you know on TV you had the the six
o'clock news or the 11 o'clock news and
you know you saw everybody watch that
whether you're liberal or conservative
I'm in 1984 when Ronald Reagan won I
mean he won California he won 49 states
out of 50 I'm not endorsing Ronald
Reagan or say anything against him
either but I saying is that things
weren't as polarized and then later on
you had 24-hour cable news so you had
Fox News on one side and MSNBC on the
other and everybody just watched what
their own echo chamber was I mean every
every channel added so necro chamber
with the blogosphere and with the
internet that became even more
pronounced so there's a lot of
polarization and I think it's getting to
a point and we're seeing this with the
regressive lesson left on the trumpian
right you know I think that there is
that kind of polarization is something
that a lot of reasonable rational people
are not feeling it's not working for
them they're actually frustrated
and I really hope that they do they're
okay to let go of the traditional left
and right labels because I they're
practically meaningless right now I
don't think they mean anything and I
just be human beings thinking human
beings I love that a perfect ending and
I love the fact that we've connected and
you'll always have an ally over here so
next time hopefully we can do this in
person when you make it out to Los
Angeles so I want to thank alyre is be
his book comes out next year but in the
meantime you can follow his regressive
smackdowns on twitter thank you guys for
watching and we'll see you next time
you